[Musique]
il ya peu de temps encore je me sentais
frustré impuissant révolter lorsque
chaque semaine je découvrais un nouveau
scandale économique
l'exploitation des enfants dans les
mines de coltan les conditions
désastreuses dans le textile le scandale
des abattoirs la liste est longue avec
une question mais qu'est ce que je peux
faire tout seul pour changer cela
posons-nous d'abord cette question
quelle est l'origine de ces scandales
ce bus a une capacité de soixante deux
places 6e bus transportait les plus
riches personnes du monde
il aurait le même poids financier que la
moitié de la population mondiale qui
veut ce type de monde aujourd'hui 85 %
des bénéfices d'une multinationale sont
reversés aux actionnaires
autrement dit c'est là-bas que tout se
décide dans la bourse
les dirigeants les employés les cadres
ne sont que des relais ils sont les
premiers à subir les conséquences
nous le voyons au sein des entreprises
avec l'augmentation de ces syndromes que
vous connaissez peut-être tous
le burn out le burn-out celui de
l'épuisement professionnel par l'ennui
et le dernier
théorisée par deux chercheurs qui
concerne pas mal de monde
le burn out celui d'exécuter des tâches
qui sont contraires avec son éthique
personnelle
prenons du recul et posons nous cette
question et si ces entreprises étaient
devenus malades
et qu'elle avait besoin de nous pour
retrouver un peu de sens
les actionnaires sont des personnes qui
se focalisent uniquement en partie sur
la rentabilité de leur investissement
il y en a peut-être ce soit parmi nous
mais honnêtement qui voudrait que son
investissement soit négatif absolument
personne
c'est normal le problème est que nous ne
parlons pas la même langue
selon une étude de l'inserm
en france le chômage du 5 fois plus que
les accidents de la route
les plans licenciements les
délocalisations le mal être des employés
l'accaparement des terres des ressources
ça ne leur parle pas aux actionnaires la
réduction des coûts l'augmentation de la
productivité le contrôle du flux
d'approvisionnement c'est beaucoup plus
clair c'est concret l'éthique ne
s'incarne d'un rien et à aucun moment
dans leur vision économique sans éthique
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
que le système dérive par nature c'est
systémique et c'est la logique de leur
paradis
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire comment
concrètement peut-on guérir ce système
tout d'abord on sait que l'un des
indicateurs d'un système sain c'est la
présence de contre-pouvoir normalement
les institutions l'état est là pour
veiller à ça mais savez vous qu'il ya
entre 15000 et 30000 lobbyistes
rien qu'à bruxelles le simple écart
entre ces chiffres en dit long sur tout
le chemin qui nous reste à faire
les gaffes à google apple facebook
amazon sont l'exemple même de cette
absence de contre-pouvoir souvent
le monopole la domaine d'activité
présente des risques
les régulateurs sont là pour sa victime
aussi des lobbys mais le système a une
grosse faille et savez vous quel est le
caillou dans la chaussure de ces grandes
entreprises non éthique dans une société
de consommation
il y à bien un acteur clef c'est nous
les consommateurs
nous sommes tous dans cette salle
consommateurs mais combien parmi nous
sont consom acteurs anna labdi à chaque
fois que vous dépenser de l'argent vous
votez pour le type de monde que vous
voulez
voilà notre pouvoir extraordinaire notre
pouvoir d'achat
celui d'acheter des biens produits par
une entreprise qui partagent mes valeurs
le bail cote ou celui de refuser ces
valeurs et refuser ces produits le
boycott
je suis ce que je consomme
c'est ça être un consom'acteur en 2002
nous étions 24 % d'européens à acheter
plus cher pour acheter responsable
nous en sommes le double aujourd'hui et
66% dans le monde
avoir une consommation socialement
responsable c'est prendre en compte les
conséquences publiques de sa
consommation privée
souvent quand je parle de boycott
je donne cet effet alors que
l'histoire nous montre que le boycott
c'est avant tout candy en 1930
martin luther king en 1955
nelson mandela en 1970 le boycott est
une liberté d'expression un outil
pacifique et efficace du faible
économiquement et politiquement mais du
fort démographiquement l'outil parfait
du peuple accessible à tous même à
l'indigné du canapé il al'avantage de
toucher les deux piliers d'une société
de consommation
l'argent qui est le nerf de l'entreprise
et l'image qui est le nerf de la marque
on sait qu'une entreprise évolue si le
marché l'obligent créons cette
obligation
créons ce déclic cette prise de
conscience avec le boycott bienveillant
fabrice epelboin a dit lors du président
tedx lyon la révolution numérique va
pousser les marques à interagir avec les
foules
nous y sommes c'est dans ce contexte
qu'est née l'association ail boycott
la première plate forme de boycott
bienveillant qui donne un droit de
réponse à l'entreprise et l'invite à
évoluer
la seule manière de clôturer une
campagne de boycott est de convaincre la
majorité des boycottant c'est les
principes de la démocratie qui sont
appliquées aux marchés c'est la
démocratie dans l'économie les
boycottant peuvent aussi proposer des
alternatives à la marque incriminée
c'est le volet buycott les consommateurs
les consom'acteurs votent avec leur
portefeuille
lancé en juin la plateforme réunit plus
de 50000 consom'acteurs plusieurs
dialogue engagé avec les multinationales
dont une victoire c'est un c'est la
construction d'un dialogue plus
responsable plus riches entre les
consom'acteurs d'un côté et les
entreprises cacher derrière la marque de
l'autre nous sommes littéralement dans
un changement de paradigme
parce que cela touche l'ensemble des
acteurs et rééquilibre le jeu dans
domaine économique les entreprises les
entreprises peuvent pour la première
fois quantifier les tic l'éthique
devient facteur économique à prendre en
compte
autrefois nous disions aux actionnaires
notre autre notre objectif c'est 10%
voire 15% soyons fous mais tout le monde
trouvait ça génial 15%
demain nous dirons à ces mêmes
actionnaires
notre objectif est de 10% en
délocalisant tchadien mais cela implique
des risques notamment de boycott qui
peuvent faire chuter notre rentabilité
là tout de suite on réfléchit à deux
fois
parce que les tic commence à parler
économiquement les entreprises peuvent
aussi dialoguer avec les boycottant
sur le schéma que vous allez voir c'est
le résultat des votes des boycotts
ensuite à la réponse des différentes
entreprises souvent multinationales donc
on peut voir que oasis a convaincu 88,8
% des boycottant les consom'acteurs ne
sont pas dans une logique punitif
ils sont dans un dialogue c'est vraiment
important
parlons-en des consom'acteurs les
consommateurs ont enfin levier pour agir
contre ces injustices économiques
ils ne sont plus seuls loin du clicis
c'est une action collectif individualisé
ils sont acteurs et déterminée comme le
prouve cette image
cette image a été prise par une
consommatrice suite à la campagne de
boycott contre petit navire fidèle
cliente depuis 35 ans elle renvoie ses
produits je vous demande de vous mettre
dans l'état d'esprit de la personne de
ce directeur de marketing qui va
recevoir ce produit ce colis malgré les
millions dans la publicité
malgré les campagnes de promotion une
consommatrice refusent de consommer des
produits déjà acheté pour des raisons
éthiques
les tic commence à lui parler on voit
qu'il ya un nouvel acteur qui a émergé
un acteur puissant un acteur qui sera
l'allié de poids pour toutes ces
personnes qui veulent apporter plus des
tic au sein même de leur entreprise
ces agents du changement qui souvent
sont impuissants et démunis le boycott
va pousser les entreprises à prioriser
les pierres éthiques
en s'appuyant sur ces personnes là nous
allons créer des cellules de guérison au
sein des entreprises
c'est un allié de poids aussi pour les
ong qui travaillent sur le terrain qui
sont dans un rapport de force sans cesse
avec les entreprises lors d'une campagne
de boycott
l'entreprise doit convaincre des
dizaines de milliers de clients de
consommateurs on n'a pas de rapport de
force avec ses clients c'est contre
nature pour une entreprise
et c'est là toute la force et la
subtilité du boycott bienveillant
j'aimerais vous donner le témoignage de
l'association vida qui a eu gain de
cause sur notre plateforme
le boycott bienveillant est une
révolution dans notre rapport avec les
marques et incarne un outil puissant
pour appuyer nos combats et les lobbys
les décideurs dans tout cela ils sont
complètement court-circuité le système
est basé sur la décentralisation du
pouvoir il ne s'appuie plus sur quelques
personnes avec qui les lobbys décide de
dîners généralement mais sur des
dizaines de milliers d'acteurs difficile
de dîner avec quarante mille personnes
sap a un sacré budget donc maintenant
que la solution est quasiment évidente
soyez le changement que vous voulez voir
dans le monde comme le disait un certain
gandhi soyez consom acteur boycotter
seul c'est bien ensemble c'est le
contre-pouvoir et avec bienveillance
c'est le changement merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]